brennick happy to see that go down he
struggled just a bit against Atlanta on
Wednesday that after the two-game
absence because of back stiffness Sixers
in the open floor
Covington hit it strong by then sentence
with your employer from Croatia they
signed him once again to the two-year
free agent jail he ended last year the
Washington Wizards Dario shards getting
an open look in rhythm cartoons back in
2007 now playing with a sports different
NBA changed it against sit-ins in deep
and no-man's land and it's going to be
interesting to see how long Nate
McMillan exposes darren collison geyser
taught Joelle's thus early not normal
that give it to a guard and run filled
that lane he would have got hot rod what
about the place going
how about Collison try to beat sentence
with his quickness had been having the
final words
Simmons again hosting Collison fine
shore edge for three
[Applause]
[Music]
Collison it's worth three Oh got to get
a hand up six is fortunate that time
kasi got an open look Covington with a
naked 3 no six are underneath Simonton
now young is on him somehow kept his
dribble and if Jerryd Bayless
once again and getting to last five or
six minutes of game action to the table
awawa caparelli Perrysville three at six
eleven 240 that's not bad oh it's not
bad but it's not enough tonight then
Simmons
giving in and stroking to prevent only a
second [ __ ] he came it up the sentence
and it's working over Bogdanovich Hey
laurie chesley oh man finish by Big Bang
cuz JJ's been so hot he gained so much
attention that opens up the court for
big bed look at him able to go one I
want Bogdanovic jumper as well it's the
same every time as in motion pretty
reliable Simmons got it done
he was following in his tracks just in
case the first initials very important
in the Netherlands
Simmons after the steel gets it back
from ends bead taking all comers behind
oh that would have brought the house
down
no sometimes mark having conspired part
of Dario struggles because when you get
touches and you can't ease your way into
the game as Stefan elbow juggler
Simmons hasn't me there it is and he
came up short Joelle somehow came away
with a Miss Bayliss diving on the floor
to keep it alive cut meat in for a drag
any business lab the major here me bring
the house lab was right there and he
couldn't connect